[Music]
thank you
now let's turn our attention to America
and the news that Hunter Biden the
president's Troublesome son has accepted
or at least he and his legal team have
accepted a plea bargain that will mean
he is charged uh two on two counts of a
federal tax offense uh and one of on a
gun misdemeanor these are relatively
light charges uh say a lot of
Republicans compared to what he could be
charged with I'm joined Now by Charles
Lipson who is a professor of political
science at the University of Chicago and
a much-loved spectator contributor
Charles can we start with the legal side
of this what does this mean for Hunter
Biden
well it means he escapes with a slap on
the wrist
the charges uh that uh they seem to have
agreed to are
um light ones and the
um and it's not clear
the the the
it's clear that he will not serve any
jail time he'll be on probation if the
judge
uh accepts the plea deal the the final
uh decision is always up to the judge
and we don't know who the judge is but
um uh it's likely that the this will be
accepted although there's a possibility
there could be a short uh jail time it's
also worth noting that Hunter's parents
have backed him and that President Biden
has said that he did not interfere in
any way which is not quite true uh
because he made public statements that
he not only supported his son which any
uh decent parent would do but that his
son had done no wrong and therefore uh
as the head of the executive branch and
all of the judicial functions the
prosecutorial functions within it he was
sending a clear message whether that had
any effect we don't know but it is not
true
that he
he did nothing it's also worth noting
that the real issue is not whether uh
given these charges he should serve time
in jail it would be perfectly
appropriate for a first-time offender
with these relatively light charges uh
to not spend time in jail although it
would also be appropriate if he did
spend some time in jail the real issues
are whether he could have been charged
with something much more serious
and whether or not in order to get this
plea deal he was required uh to proffer
before
the grand jury and uh the people
Prosecuting him and a profit would be a
complete statement of what he had
actually done and for example he was not
charged with being a a foreign agent
which he could have easily been charged
with and Paul manafort was charged with
and spent time in jail for so uh and
that was the basic uh grift uh the scam
that they were running it wasn't really
a scam they were they were trading off
of his name with foreign entities to get
leverage within the United States
government whether that's a crime or not
it it depends on a lot of things but
it's pretty clear he was acting as
foreign agent and they didn't charge him
with that and it's not clear he
proffered anything he told the grand
jury or told the prosecutors anything
and there is a separate but connected
investigation
um going on that look by the house
oversight committee which is run by
Republicans because they have a majority
in the house into Hunter Biden's
business dealings this has no
relationship this criminal proceedings
has no relationship with with that house
oversight committee does it
no formal relationship but obviously a
political relationship uh viewers
outside of uh uh the United States
should know that because the Republicans
control the House of Representatives
they can send subpoenas that doesn't
mean that the subpoenas have to be
complied with if they come before the
government because if they're not
complied with the House of
Representatives uh would send that
matter over to the Department of Justice
which is controlled by Joe Biden and
they would be unlikely to prosecute but
you can still subpoena Witnesses in the
house in the Senate it would require the
approval of the majority party which is
the Democrats they only control a very
slight majority just as the Republicans
do in the house but they will not
approve any uh subpoenas to look into
the bidens at this point now it may may
be the case that if Joe Biden's
popularity is so low and the Democrats
decide they just have to jettison him
that that they would turn on him but
that hasn't happened yet well and the
the house oversight committee LED as as
I said by Republicans has made it very
clear that they are not going to be put
off by this uh sweetheart plea plea deal
I think uh James Comey called it uh and
and they will pursue
um some quite intriguing uh details that
they have Unearthed uh namely a sort of
bank wire transfer from a Chinese entity
to an associate of the Biden family uh
three months I think it was before after
Joe Biden uh resigned as vice president
in 2017 and they will follow the money
and see where that money went uh do you
think the Biden family the Biden
Administration are despite their
appearances Joe Biden says it's all
Malarkey publicly they are do you think
they are deeply concerned about this
they should be
um the
um the house is uncovering a lot of
information
um that there was a family-wide effort
to monetize Joe Biden's position
um the Democrats position on this is
that if Joe Biden cannot be directly
connected
to any of that then
then it's just a matter of family
members trading off of his name which is
uh not illegal I would draw a
distinction here between well there two
distinctions one is something can be
deeply corrupt and not necessarily
illegal
and whether that has an implication uh
uh for the body politic is up to what
voters think and that brings us to the
second point which is the the country is
so deeply divided if you look at what
and divide it along ideological terms
Britain has been divided along
ideological terms for many decades
because labor and uh and Tori are really
ideologically opposed to each other in a
way that was not true for a long time
between Democrats and Republicans in
America Democrats were more Liberal
Republicans were more conservative but
the the uh ideological differences have
become much deeper and if you show me a
an opinion piece that says
um that this is an appropriate treatment
of Hunter Biden and everything is fair
and hunky-dory uh I can tell you that
was written by a Democrat if you tell me
that it was soft treatment and other
people don't get this kind of treatment
that was written by a Republican
now
that difference no longer applies to
Donald Trump
and that's that's a whole separate issue
we haven't talked about Trump but I
would say that there are a lot of
Republicans that are splitting off
from Trump it's begun with the
intellectual classes the people who
write op-eds and so forth who are deeply
Disturbed some deeply disturbed by
Trump's Behavior some by the fact that
he might not be elected others by the
fact that he might be
and uh so he's a he's a figure like a
Boris Johnson who divides people within
his own party
well a lot of trump people and Trump
himself are crying foul they're talking
about double standards as I suppose you
imagine it would
um and of course there is a difference
between Hunter Biden whose president's
son and Donald Trump who is seeking
re-election he's seeking the Oval Office
again nonetheless uh you can see why I
think even from trying to be as
objective as possible you can see why uh
Trump supporters will look at the legal
persecution of Donald Trump and I think
it's fair to say it's a persecution
because it's happening on so many fronts
and say he could be in jail for the rest
of his life
um for holding on to documents and yet
the president's son has done far more
criminal things it seems uh and is going
to get away without any jail time
that's right but it's also against the
background of Hillary Clinton getting
off all of the uh top people in the FBI
under James Comey
uh the the name Comer uh who is
represent who is the head of the
oversight committee uh is so easy to mix
up but James Comey was the head of the
FBI and uh uh he he was not punished his
top aides were not punished it's very
clear that they misled the Pfizer courts
which are the courts that give these
secret warrants they investigated
um uh Trump for a Russian collusion that
Not only was a hoax but that they should
have known was a hoax they began
investigations according to the person
who investigated all of this John Durham
who is testifying uh before Congress now
uh they began all of this without really
an adequate pretext they clearly went
after Trump and they clearly gave
excuses to people like Hillary Clinton
uh the head of the FBI come Comey wrote
her exoneration before she had been
interviewed
and she had all of these documents on a
Home Server
why was she excused partly because she
was a Democrat say the Republicans but
also because uh President Obama had
communicated with her on that Home
Server and he would have been called as
a witness
her legal team undoubtedly threatened at
any
Court proceeding so she got off and so
for Republicans it begins to look like
all of this is two standards of justice
and for ordinary Americans it looks uh
like if you're connected in Washington
uh whether you're a democrat or a
republican if you're part of the
establishment you get different
treatment than if you're an outsider and
so it's partly
party divisions but it's also Insider
Outsider it's worth remembering
that Trump ran as an outsider indeed as
a former president he's running as an
outsider I'm coming after the Washington
establishment is what he's saying and a
lot of Republicans love that they think
that the Washington establishment uh
doesn't speak for them and that's been
increasingly true as they are governed
we Americans are governed more and more
by bureaucracies who make the rules that
are effectively the laws that govern us
so it's a big problem and
um I would say
there's been a general erosion in trust
in all governmental institutions and the
Department of Justice is uh now in the
Forefront of that people don't trust the
FBI in the way that they used to and
they don't trust the fairness of the
Department of Justice and whenever a
court rules a decision the courts are
separate branch in America but whenever
the courts rule make a ruling one of the
first things that you see in any
publication is who appointed these
judges was it a Republican or was it a
Democrat well you know that's important
information because it can tell you how
the decision was rendered but it's also
very corrosive to assist to an idea that
we have fair and impartial Blind Justice
a lot of uh the Republicans on this
house committee or or Republicans in the
party and Trump supporters are very keen
to connect Joe Biden to Hunter Biden's
Shady business business activities I
think it's fair to say there's there's
little hints there might have been
something there but there's no Smoking
Gun there's no damning evidence as yet
if no smoking gun or damning evidence
emerges
um do you think this story really hurts
Biden at all or does it actually flip
for him and it becomes gleeful
Republicans uh gloating about this
unfortunate story of an errant sun and
Biden emerges looking like a loving
father
um all his texts to Hunter Biden seemed
to be very supportive he repeatedly says
I love you son and there's obviously a
lot of tragedy in the Biden family uh
Beau Hunter's brother died of brain
cancer
um uh Joe Biden lost his wife and child
in as a in a car crash when the two boys
were small they were both in that car
crash that frantic story is an important
part of Biden's political story I wonder
if it ends up helping him if they can't
find any evidence linking him to the
dodgy activities of Hunter Biden what
always helps to be seen as a loving
father
and the fact that your son has gone
through enormous troubles is something
many Americans can identify with many
people all around the world can identify
with uh but if this goes beyond uh
Hunter and includes other members of the
family for example his brother James uh
the grandchildren got payments we have
no indication that any of them provided
any Services other than opening doors
for people I think that the corruption
is a kind of cloud hanging over Biden
there's an irony here Biden may be one
of the weakest candidates that the
Democrats can put forward
and the irony is that Trump is probably
the weakest candidate the Republicans
can put forward so the attacks by the
other party in a way may may put a
stronger candidate into the lead uh it's
it's hard to know Biden's real problem
nobody can run against uh Biden from the
inside of the party that is a governor
or something like that but it's striking
that a real Outsider with a lot of kooky
views uh the son of the uh former uh
Attorney General Robert F Kennedy and
the nephew of President Kennedy
has gotten up into the 30 percent range
which is not an indication of how much
people like
uh Robert F Kennedy Jr in my opinion
it's an indication of how much they
dislike uh Joe Biden as the candidate
and uh and and yet Biden says he's going
to run and he's running as he did as uh
last time of what's called a basement
candidate see he's not getting out he's
not answering questions because every
time he speaks off the cuff
uh he he makes blunders sometimes quite
serious ones and every time he's seen in
public his increasing Frailty uh becomes
a problem and this is a problem for the
Democrats generally because they have
two members of the Senate who look to be
physically and mentally
incapable of performing their jobs
and that gives them the majority they
wouldn't without those two they wouldn't
have the majority now now in in both
cases there are democratic governors of
those two states who could appoint their
successors but uh but it's a problem
that that the Democratic party's
leadership looks increasingly like and
drop off and breshnev in their final
years where they were sort of held up by
other people to do what they're doing
well Charles I could listen to you
talking about Hunter Biden all day but I
think we must end it there sadly uh
thank you very much for coming on to
spectator TV
[Music]
foreign